aber wir sind schnell sie an einer neuen
folge das thema jetzt wird ganz
interessant glaube ich wenn wir alle
andere ansichten haben wer wird
deutscher fußball-meister
bayern bayern bayern eintracht frankfurt
20 rang 14 aber keine einzige person die
frankfurt fensters und mein fahrlehrer
der erste schub am anfang ja aber ich
bin schon keine anspricht und auch lange
ich war früher irgendwann mal kein also
sechs jahre alt war war ich mir bayern
fan geil erfolgs fenja volkskundler wenn
ein tor aus dem süden kommt oder so dann
wird man bayern fan weil die gut sind
erfolgs fan das einfach nicht aber ich
bin zwei mal seit 17 jahren und in der
saison wo ich bei entfernt wurde wird
kann ich euch sagen da war das wirklich
so dass bayern war auf abstiegsrang
das ist wirklich so gewesen welches
saison auf einem abstiegsrang die ersten
vier fünf spielen wir ganz weit unten
angekommen also erzählen konzentrat aus
der nähe der ich fan geworden bin ja ich
habe damals selber fußball gespielt in
kumpel von mir dass ich habe angefangen
hat er keine ahnung so wirklich das war
nämlich gegen die jugend oder so ähnlich
druck hinter den kopfball bist so süß
ich hatte keine ahnung allgemein so von
fußball
dann kam er so anja heute abend bayer
nicht so jo ich gucke dazu an
haben sie zwar verpackt aber ich von
schweinsteiger folge erst bei der em
2004 so wirklich gespielt das erste mal
naja was heißt ist nicht das erste mal
gespielt aber dass er jetzt erst einmal
in erinnerung aber der kann ja auch aus
der bayern jugend ja es kann sein dass
er dabei
ja hat denn das wasser ist damals ja
auch lahm hatte bei stuttgart gespielt
hermann müller auch groß auf da bin ich
mir nicht sicher doch lahm auf jeden
fall da echt war eine wahl bei stuttgart
und dann nein da ist bei bayern
doch bitte bitte bitte rat jetzt kommt
mir das wieder zu dir kein eine art
mittelwerte das mach ich hatte keine
töten nicht töten töten ist nicht gut
absolut keine ahnung ich komme aus der
drg schreckt mich nicht dass du bist ein
mongole mich nicht tötet das was ballett
nicht wird es ja man kommt jetzt niemand
erfahren raucher mussten und eingang
machen ich helfe dir hast du was es aus
seiner kiste nehmen sehr nett danke ja
dann mach dein haus kaputt aber bitte
das weizen für die kühe
ja ich wollte mir ein bisschen essen
machen aber ich habe auch gewählt doch
sie jetzt auch boni wenn das skelett
card gekeltert müsstest du eigentlich
braucht ja warum
ich habe bei mir ist niemand singt
einbauen will
du kannst du mit instant gestimmt
vielleicht war das alles hier was zu
essen
rock the honey honey honey ihr das hier
das ist einer der alles dinge oder
wasser liegen das unfair xp ist aber
nein so etwas kannst dich zu mir
teleportieren alter ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass er tot ist
ja ich hatte mich ist ja manchmal gleich
umso indirekte beleuchtung bei den
bäumen damit da nicht immer was pont ja
macht das direkte bedeutung sozialer
sachen liebe dort seine farm für alle
ja weil du selber nichts bauen kann ich
wollte eigentlich als ich meine zum
keller bauen
dehner deine diskin crafter ich ja sie
sind die besten vbt oder so was papa
vw-werk in eurer meinung nach das hobby
täter verfolgt erst überhaupt verfolgt
so teilweise nicht so ganz so dass sie
so alles weiß aber manchmal ein paar
runden an
nur wer neuer favorit so 5 und bei dir
minecraft aquino schoss gar nicht gucke
ich nicht ob ich nicht und eigentlich
weekend und pimpf weekends ach so weil
er auch so gut mitmacht früh an sich ein
quartett nur weil vorbild displays
mitgemacht
er hat auch 2011 mit gemacht die
variante bei vw
deswegen nicht beim normalen vw thema ja
wast nicht dabei aber was jetzt wieder
gesund aber auch lernen dass auch
ziemlich schnell habe ich auch meine
tracklist da gepackt hier und vom 5
ja wenn ich auch ziemlich schnell geht
es also so einfach dass das einfach
nicht so viel selbstironie auch dabei
und einfach passt einfach alles
vor allem allerdissen ihnen die einzige
die gegen haben du hast
silhouette eines stativs ich wollte
jetzt eigentlich ihre strafe holen nein
du kommst du keine ahnung hast du
bekommst dann holz zurück ich hab's alte
genommen sorry aber ich brauche dieses
tannenholz opernhaus ach es gibt nun
zurück weiter ich geb dir den den 63
stück zurück ich komme und ob ich ändern
nur mal die textur von dem holz weil da
sorgen was anderes ich weiß nicht oder
also wenn ihr könnt mir mal aus von
mieser von meine kraft und von honeywell
von heine kraft irgendwelchen meine
konstanz und von janina kraft irgendeine
holz textur die ich hierfür nehmen soll
junge ist das ist das ist das holz von
diesen tannen hier könne mir mal so als
kommentar sagen so welche superzoom und
aplomb ist schreibt extra kein kommentar
bitte schreibt kommentare besten kräften
lese genau wobei ich muss sagen ich lese
echt auch die folgen bei dir lese ich
voll 4 kommentare ich habe seit meinem
alter die bei dir einmal einen kommentar
mit 40 doch ich dachte mal den er voll
behindert aber irgendwie hat er doch mal
die tabelle oder kürzlichen bewusst
steht das gleiche ich meine natur das
abbauen ich muss einfach was wir im
moment was du bist du nicht bist du
mensch sehe das ganz abbauen
hu abgezogen
danke der nachfrage ich glaube ich bin
nicht mit beziehungsweise noch nicht
noch den aber du kriegst du musst du
musst dich auf fügte sich beziehen
sondern es geht ja auch psychisch
sich immer wieder gar nichts bei dir
mein kraftpakete kriege ich kann gekräht
frau kochen das macht jeder verbessert
als manche jetzt immer problemlos von
jedem wort
aber den hat er schon weisen der
besteller um einfach um einen so guten
satz zitieren unser lehrer als auch
angekündigt einer der besten setzte der
je geschrieben wurde
passt auf von dir ja wenig von mir
von franz kafka jemand jemand musste
josef k verleumdet haben denn ohne dass
er etwas böses getan hätte wurde er
eines morgens verhaftet
das war doch mal bitte noch mal wozu
hört ja jemand musste josef k verleumdet
haben denn ohne dass er etwas böses
getan hätte wurde er eines morgens
verhaftet handelt von spaghetti
das ist der erste satz von der prozess
von kafka und alleine diesen satz was
man interpretieren jaja ich das einfach
das eine perfekte beginn für den roman
weil ihr schon demnächst es auch schon
gespannt weil man wusste denn man weiß
nicht was josef k hat meist direkt in
der hand und will man bei schloss und
das irgendwie was getan hat aber so ich
nach allem was er gemacht hat ja er wird
halt wenigen was angeklagt was er nicht
verbrochen hat ja und er weiß nicht
warum mehr guter satz na toll
oft fragt mein deutschlehrer alt ist er
550 a facebook
hast du noch diese platten die du über
das ding ist gelegt hast weil er ist
mein lehrers türke beste beste die ganze
holzmodell
spendierte man den leuten
wir sind nicht bei allen tricks nicht
lügen erzählt ihr nicht so solche
risiken da der hat facebook dessen 30
oder so 29 30 dann kann ich euch mal
schicken da ist erdenberger dem 2 da
sowohl ziemlich glück finde so ein
lehrer hast der school franke glück ja
ich habe doch gesagt
sagen wir einfach glück es war glück
jetzt schon wieder keine rolle oder was
hallo ich brauche die wolle wofür holte
die ganze zeit wolle wird erreichen
wolle turm bauen stopp braucht es für
mein boden ich werde sonst nie fertig
mit ja nachdem eigene farm was was
eigentlich was war erhält einen seite
schon ein netter immer noch kein diamant
und kalabrien er aber eher was machst du
denn bitte ich verstehe es nicht dass
die schafe nicht wenn man da reingeht
dass sie dann wenn sie rausgehen noch in
diesem cook jetzt zum beispiel bleiben
drin und die nicht sofort aus dem jäger
aus was soll das weiß ja was denn mit
dem boden gemacht hast ja den habe ich
jetzt wieder zur erde gemacht der vater
vor rapid lpg auch frage ob er kommen
will und table tennis gamer das game so
was war das thema mein haus geil aus so
das thema war wer wird deutscher
fußball-meister war mir ganz kurz darauf
zu sprechen
werder bremen ist echt ich bin der
bremen von kindesbeinen an
aber was ich die letzten songs
zurückgespielt zusammen gespielt haben
haben die alle anträge 20 jahre 15
alles ist sowieso nicht trainer von aber
ich finde es gut dass sie so lange
trainer mal zum beispiel im vergleich zu
hamburg wo der trainer gefragt
anders da wo der trainer alles halbe
jahr wechselt findet es gutes den
trainer so lange haben unter mal an was
festhalten aber einen letzten drei vier
songs war einfach weil man weiß nicht
warum es läuft einfach nicht nur man
jetzt gegen augsburg haben sie jetzt
eine bei der aufnahme auch gerade
augsburg spiel vor ein paar tagen
der lief einfach nichts gegen den
tabellenletzten 331 was glaubt 313 sie
verkauft die haben sie noch verkauft
allerdings wie sabine emmerich
diese ist jetzt zu hoffenheim gewechselt
wegen den internationalen aussichten
das war ein sehr streitbaren devise tim
der hat ich war hamburg in bremen
hamburg und stadion da diese diesen
kung-fu-tritt gegen öl ohne damals zum
stadion da war ich im stadion ich so was
wir gerade bei hamburg bremen im stadion
weil das nordderby ist und ich mal halb
hamburg fan damals war mittlerweile echt
nicht mehr recht an weihnachten war für
zweieinhalb stunden ungefähr
ich bin auch bayern fan na ja weil man
schon dreimal im stadion mit die
schlechteste atmosphäre in allen stadien
weil er sofort sind ja eigentlich nur so
erfolgsfans sind und eigentlich so bin
ich so eine burg sind frankfurt immer
hooligans dass das mittlerweile dortmund
erfolg seit ich kenne so viele die
mittlerweile dortmund fans sind einfach
weil sie zweimal gewann sind ganz die
band früher dortmund fans weil doppelt
einer früher mal vor zehn jahren auch
gut war und haben deren eltern natürlich
so okay ist keine mannschaft bin ich
auch für in front und dann waren sie
ewig halt so kein fußball fan weil
dortmund nichts gerissen und jetzt sind
sie guten jetzt alle wieder jörg poschen
immer drucken fehlen
aber was ich halt ein bisschen scheiße
findet es da wirklich ja ich bin seit
zehn jahren hier als letzte schnitt york
keine ahnung wieso bist bereit wären
würde ich sind gut das ist so
erfolgsfans aber ich meine wenn man
jetzt wirklich für jedes spiel
verfolgten startet ist uns als dann kann
man das nicht erfolgt
doch graf kugel
ich stehe dazu extra volks fällen ist ja
nicht ob du es ja gut aber wenn man bei
endfälligkeit aus bayern kommt oder
irgendwie andere verbindung zum verein
hat dann ist das halt weil sie gut sind
und sei es dass weil man als kleines
kind niemals es ja bei meinen kleinen
geschwistern die frage macht also meine
meinung meine große schwester in hamburg
fertig bin bremen fällen um eine kleine
geschwister die sind so weit dass die
überzeugenden immer bremens guten 1 hsv
es besser ab remes guten ein hedge fonds
besser immer so hin her und die fragen
wie man ja wie hat hamburg gespielt wie
bremen gespielt sagen sie da bin ich in
bremen gewonnen hat oder wenn habe nur
gewohnheit in hamburg fällen soll es
kleines kind ist man auch gerne mal
ferien von dem der gewonnen hat und
lassen also erfolgsfans und wenn du dann
halt früher als kind in hamburg bayern
verlassen bis jetzt immer noch erfolgs
fan weil nun mal nur aus erfolg nur weil
die erfolg hatten fan geworden bist von
denen die opfer
ich bin habe ich mir das ist ja noch gar
kein basta
ja man kann genauso gut sagt du bist
wahrscheinlich damals auch fällen
geworden bei bremen da war neben war im
fernsehen oder und hat im ui-cup
bisschen was ist also die qualifikation
europas wird gemüse und ost verein also
ehemalige ostblockstaaten da haushoch
verloren sowie 81 oder sowas
und dann wurde ich fan von denen ich
mitleid hatte darin bestimmt keine fans
außerdem waren die grünen und grün ist
meine lieblingsfarbe